كانت طبيبه في احدى المنظمات الدوليه وقد
تعطلت عن العمل جراء الفرمان الجديد
لطالبان بمنع السيدات من العمل في
المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه تقول ان راتبها
كان المصدر الوحيد لعائلتها واطفالها
السته
التزمت المنزل بعد ما اعلن الطالبان انها
لا تسمح لنا بالعمل زوج عاطل عن العمل
وضعنا الاقتصادي ضعيف نعيش حياه صعبه في
منزل باجره
بهار هي الاخرى كانت عامله في المجال
الصحي في احدى المنظمات وقد تعطلت عن
العمل ايضا وابوها قد توفي منذ زمن وهي
المعينه الوحيده لعائلتها التي تعيش في
وضع اقتصادي صعب كما تقول
والمنظمات بدورها قامت بتسريح العامله
فيها وبالتالي لم استطع الاستمرار في
العمل يقول عدد من الطبيبات والعاملات في
مجال الصحه ان القيود المختلفه التي
فرضتها طالبان على النساء الافغانيات قد
اضرت بهن كثيرا بحسب الطبيبات والعاملات
في مجال الصحه فان القرار بمنع السيدات من
العمل في المنظمات قد خلق مخاطر قاتله
لملايين النساء والاطفال الذين يحتاجون
الى عمل الطبيبات
العربيه كابول